the next panel is the last before dinner
so stay with me bear with me and it's
going to be called design Futures and
the role of innovation so it's going to
be you know we're getting closer and
closer to understanding really what it
means to talk about design Futures you
know what it means to talk about it
means to understand what the role of
design can be the role of innovation how
one can both read possible Futures and
try to actually design them into action
and we're going to have two wonderful
speakers one the first is Michaela magas
Michaela magas has interoperational
interoperability at the Key of
everything that she does I know that
here in Singapore you like to use the
term
multi-hyphenated and there's very few
people that are as hyphenated as she is
but she really Bridges together the
world of science of art of design of of
like technology academic research
industry and she advises the European
commission and the G7 leaders on how to
implement and how to really Foster
Innovation then we're going to have also
dulisha Kula Surya and you know the
title titles are all there so I give you
my version of what they do and then you
can read the BIOS in on the website but
I want to quote something that he
mentions in his bio he says that what I
do is study the changing World period
get inspired period talk to people
period build things period contemplate
navel Naval that's important period
create compelling models for a new world
and understand why they matter period
connect across Bridges to create
uncommon Partnerships and that's truly
what he does and we'll hear from him and
you're gonna start you're gonna have to
bear with me because I'm gonna be the
first Speaker of this session I'm Gonna
Shine the laser light in my light when
the two minutes are up so I'm gonna
start with a presentation that tells you
a about the core idea about the
Symposium that design is the enzyme for
progress and I'm going to show you some
past examples that are going to show you
why and one is the most classical the
internet you know when people ask me why
do you say that well revolutions happen
in science and technology and design
makes them into life the internet used
to be like this and this is the 80s
before it was even worse but anyway it
was lines of code and commands and only
few people really were comfortable with
it until here we go in 1993 the
designers of the Mosaic interface came
about and all of a sudden we had buttons
we had windows we had hyperlinks and
everybody could use the internet and
then when everybody was on board
progress happened and interfaces became
more and more akin to humans and humans
more akin to interfaces and similarly
this is an exhibition that I curated in
2001 and somebody here in Singapore
reminded me of it just a few days ago it
was called work spheres it was the
beginning of nomadic work you know you
could work on the go you could bring
your own laptop even though it was at
that time something like this and you
could connect with home even though
nothing ever worked and this server was
always down and you had to wait for the
telephone line to work but already we
were concerned about what it meant to
work at home whether it was worth going
to the office or not this was 2001 the
conversation was the same that we're
having now after the pandemic only at
that time it was on the audio and not
also video but the designers that
participated in that created solutions
that truly could be applied today
because they're more about habits and
behaviors than they are about the object
or the technology that's what Innovation
is design comes in many different shapes
it is sometimes the old adage of problem
solving like the work of Alex gold who's
trying to replenish the Barrier Reef by
creating this 3D printed ceramic
trellises that can then be seeded with
some coral and then left to Foster and
fester for many many decades or it can
be you see it here in a video it's this
is a prototype but it works really well
because it's accepted also by the uh by
the inhabitants of the sea or it can be
about creating branding so the
coronavirus is the kind of gray blob and
that's what it became in the hands of
two illustrators from the center of
disease controls in Atlanta who made it
into this deep water mine really
threatening with the red spikes like
Hellraiser and all of a sudden it was
branded all over the world as this
terrifying entity that needed to be
warned off and kept at bar so that's
design it is the trellis it is the The
Branding it is information this is from
2011. it's uh my friend and shower's
friend Eric Chanda was the director of
the Eugene OR the Beijing design week
and had commissioned this Cafe in which
people were taught how much water was
needed for any dish that they ordered so
trying to make people understand
awareness through visualization design
and by really spreading the word I'm
just telling you all of all the
different forms of design that exist
that are not cute chairs but in some
cases they are cute chairs in the case
of former fantasma I call their work
investigative design they use the beauty
of these pieces of furniture to talk
about the underbelly of the electronic
waste system around the world beautiful
objects that could be produced by the
finest Italian manufacturer of office
furniture but in truth they're all made
of E-Waste they attract the eye and all
of a sudden this Trojan Horse leads you
into interviews with NGO
laborers with people that are enslaved
and indentured in recycling all of the
precious metals all over the world so
you understand through this kind of
Outlook The Works that Mei Ling Locker
showed earlier in the afternoon reminded
me a lot of this algae platform it's
about using what is the waste product of
our own pollution algae that are
proliferating everywhere transforming
them with easy chemical processes into
bioplastics and then using these
bioplastics to 3D print objects from
your own material culture little teacups
in Istanbul little baskets in Sardinia
this Luma Al Foundation that you might
have heard about already has been doing
this for a few years going in different
parts of the world and working with
local culture to make this happen and I
was laughing at what Stephen was talking
about before because I got very familiar
with larvae excrement by working with
Mary oxman in this 3D Pavilion that was
installed at MoMA that was made by 16500
silkworm larvaes that poop with abandon
when they start making their silk thread
and therefore you have all these little
dots and people were walking and I was
telling them that's
so it really is about changing also a
way of living and also changing way to
relate to Nature this amazing uh image
is by Laura Aguilar a photographer that
didn't have a chance to meet because she
passed away before I could get to her
but that's her self-portrait in front of
a boulder it's amazing and it gives me
shivers every time I see it yeah we're
we're good at relating with animals okay
there's more of a conversation even with
rivers but try connecting with a boulder
there's something gorgeous and inspiring
about the creative uh the creatives
around us whether they're designers or
Architects or artists that can really
open worlds for us interspecies is
something that we will discuss later
also with Michaela magas and it was
already hinted at in previous
conversations but one of the features
that we really need to approach is
thinking about ourselves as part of
nature not not as outside nature
therefore this assembly future assembly
by Studio other spaces which is
basically all of Eliason that I was also
part of in the Venice viennale was about
thinking in the anniversary of the
United United Nations thinking of a
future un that also incorporates other
species and what they need and what they
want so this attempt to get closer to
the rest of Nature and understand what
it wants truth is we're living really in
a systemic world and we cannot discount
what we don't know enough or what we
don't know yet and this is a new company
by a friend Adam Bligh that's called
system you know system.com he wants to
become a Wikipedia that instead of
giving you single entries gives you the
connectedness of every single entry that
you get to and wants to be like with
Wikipedia therefore open source and
transform the way we know and we think
which is what every designer and every
presenter that we saw today is trying to
do because in the end we need to really
create a mind shift that is not only
about otherness but it's also about time
as we have said and we have to start
thinking beyond our physical capability
of thinking in two three four
generations ahead of us and then no more
these images have changed by NASA are
online you can get to them they show the
before and after as if you were plastic
surgery of different parts of the world
before and after could be three months
or three centuries but change happens it
really does for those who want to not
believe it it is visible and tangible so
just go NASA images of change and you'll
see it this is the trianale DI Milano
which I did a few years ago broken
nature and it was shown there and this
is what leads us to projects that are at
the large scale like epic projects like
the great green wall of Africa going
from the Atlantic Ocean to the Indian
Ocean and creating a 21 miles not sorry
I I don't remember how many miles but I
remember it's 21 countries deep
ribbon of green that tries to change the
earth climate and replenish what we're
losing in the Amazons and 21 countries
that normally might be at war with each
other are working together using their
own cultural methods uh agricultural
methods to actually make this happen so
projects at that scale are what really
makes us think in long terms and I
really love this quote by Frank Ramsey
which says that discounting the interest
of future people is ethically
indefensible and arises merely from the
weakness of imagination and we could add
other species instead of other people
but it truly is that way imagination and
creativity are extremely important for
us today and that's why we're happy to
this to have this Symposium and I'm
gonna close with a piece by Patricia
piccinini there as a retrospective of
her work right now at the art Science
Museum and I had this piece at the end
of the trianale because we have to start
loving not only black soldier flies
larvae but also species that we might
not know yet and only by really trying
compassion we will be able to move
forward as designers as civil servants
and as Citizens so thank you very much
and now I'm gonna call to the stage
I'm gonna call Michaela to the states
thank you and thank you Paola for this
uh for allowing me to be here in this
fantastic company I have seen so many
synergies between speakers especially
with a new European Bauhaus initiative
which are now running uh we are now
running uh as part of the European
commission and I would love to speak
with you over dinner uh with all of the
different important synergies there
um but
um over the past 10 years I have been
feeding policy directly from Grassroots
creative experimentation
um
Building Systems and testing systems
with Frontier Technologies with a global
multi-disciplinary multi-generational
community that now counts over 8 000
contributors and of course challenging
ourselves to think to rethink our mental
models and sometimes also what we can be
as humans
so this behind me is Victoria Modesta
in 2016
we fitted Victoria with a system that
allowed her to train her brain to
control projection mapping and lighting
environments as an additional mode of
expression in addition to all of the
other things she had to do during her
performance and we thought this might be
really really difficult for her but by
the end of the week she was actually
able to do it seamlessly so not only
does this sort of illuminate how plastic
our brain is but also the fact that we
were now creating new methods of
expression for people with our systems
which actually allowed them to to
express their knowledge and their
capabilities in new ways so the best way
that I can draw an analogy and it's very
very simple analogy is you know before
someone built a piano there was no such
thing as a Pianist virtuoso
so we decided to take this further and
in our labs in Helsinki we put at the
center Rika Hanan uh very proud to be a
blind singer and vocal coach very
accomplished vocal coach from the
sibelius academy and we adapted a system
from clinical trials which allows people
to train to control anxiety attacks to
instead control the musical scale
and people in the lab started to train
with this system and it took them around
two hours to start to be were able to
even move up and down the musical scale
which actually is quite remarkable but
when Rika put the neurofeedback sensor
on she was able to play instantly
without training and all of a sudden
they dawned on us
and that someone who in the mechanical
era was defined as less label-bodied was
now with the new systems we were
designing far more talented than the
rest of us
so of course
I feed this directly to policy because
it has to encourage policy makers to
reconsider how they Define ability and
the future of work or how we build
future systems
and the bar had been set very high for
us very early on because when we were
working when we were running in
Cambridge Massachusetts with MIT Harvard
and Microsoft's research there was a
bunch of luminary academics that
assembled inspired by what we were doing
and decided to create a Manifesto for us
which actually effectively stated that
what we were creating was a space of
common understanding now I must say I
have since made myself made it made it a
business for myself to actually create
spaces for common understanding
including across industry sectors uh in
at high level in Europe which I you know
we can talk about later but
um in this case it was actually
acknowledging the fact that we were
placing music at the center as a social
glue this is us at the uh with the
London Symphony Orchestra at the
Barbican in London
um with the brainwave quartet bridging
disciplines
and This Is Us in New Zealand
um bridging uh indigenous and digital
Technologies
um and this guy on the right is a
hip-hop artist
um uh Paola was talking about rock stars
we have loads of rock stars in our in
our community
and this is bridging species so in 2015
robertina shebinich a wonderful artist
who is member of our community for many
many years and currently her stuff is
latest collaboration is exhibited in Los
Angeles
this is a huge tank of jellyfish that
communicate via chemical reaction and
this is converted into signal and then
the artist plays back to the system so
basically creating a multi-species
concert
and then in 2016 when we had one of the
worst immigration crisis in Europe
um we actually fought really hard to get
a visa for Ahmad bakri on the right from
Palestine to come in person and
collaborate with ranidar from Israel
using ancient and modern Technologies so
our ideas are fun foundational aim is to
create a Level Playing Field that sort
of inclusion that doesn't divide people
into categories but rather asks where do
we converge and when we bring people
into this space of common understanding
it is not about canceling each other out
it's about every personal experience and
knowledge helping others to grow so it
is also not about defining people
exactly as per their profession but
acknowledging that we can be many things
or we can grow into many things so for
instance here more rock stars Imogen
Heap as a blockchain activist or a
famous Professor of AI robotics Danica
as a fashion designer this was these
were women in charge of all technology
areas in our biggest event to date which
was pre-pandemic and I deliberately did
this because as a result
800 plus Hands-On participants
53 percent declared themselves as women
in a technology prototyping event now I
am emphasizing this because loads of
people try to do this and then unless
you segregate women into the women in
Tech thing this simply doesn't happen
and during the pandemic we immersed
ourselves in natural ecosystems and we
started to question our value systems
our societal value systems we have
generated maps that do not acknowledge
the value of the oceans or the value of
um of the richness of our biospheres
that are essential for our survival so
we started to create new types of
markers in this case for instance using
the ocean as an instrument and doing an
experiment in the First underwater
overtone singing
and this is on your markova a Harvard
fellow who is coming back this year to
continue this huge project that involves
many nations because at the same time
what we do is we run a series of global
satellites for different universities
around the world who beam in and uh who
then use this as an acupuncture point in
their students personal development and
some as part of their curricula and I
always say that if every person involved
in this processes can take one step
forward in their personal development we
will have a phenomenal societal
transformation so one of the reasons why
this can happen is that we are not
afraid to take moonshots 83 fantastic
Minds from New Zealand to Alaska
send their voices to the Moon from 25
meters on the ground in a decommissioned
nuclear reactor in Stockholm via the
dwindling radio telescope in the north
of the Netherlands and after 2.4 seconds
their voices were returned into their
ear and not because we're trying to make
scientific breakthroughs but because
this puts us in a completely different
mental space because based on this we
can confidently say that for us the
future of work is based on missions
and so basically we always say this
because we can base it on tangible
evidence that we don't predict the
future we invented thank you
[Applause]
where are you
thank you
I thought you had something to read I'm
like oh I'm hungry no it's Ganesh
everybody's hungry that's why we know
that and everybody's tired it's been a
long day it's been an inspiring day but
it's been a long day so I'm going to
stick to my seven minutes because she's
gonna start flashing lights at me at
five
um so the edge center for the edge The
Edge I'm going to talk to you about
today is the metaverse how many of you
have heard of the mirrors
everybody should have this one right how
many of you think the metaverse is
inevitable
only a few okay let me try and convince
you otherwise let's start with a quick
clip
[Music]
this is Singapore 2065.
three local artists put this together
race Ben and Takeda
[Music]
this is one of the crypto Gods that's in
there
[Music]
that's Golden Mile
still there in 2065.
[Music]
so these kids put this together using an
a game engine called Unreal Engine and
they did it just to launch a music video
a music album gives you a sense of the
future I'm going to talk you through
three quick stories and then frame what
I believe the mid of us could be or what
we believe that many of us could be and
why it matters right anybody see this
concept Travis Scott Fortnight April 23
2018.
30 million people
logged on live for this 30 million
um they gross 20 million dollars from
this show nine minute show 20 million
dollars not even the Super Bowl halftime
show can do that
right this is and what they I would I
was trying to show this but we couldn't
for copyright issues go Google this see
it if you haven't it's incredible you
can only do this in a virtual
environment incredible next story
this lady Emma she's a Instagram
influencer from Japan
four hundred thousand followers
she is model for Dio Puma Nike BMW
Porsche Valentino wait a little meter
because she's a virtual human
she's made up
I still don't know how they did that
picture I'm still trying to figure that
one out however
um there are about 35 virtual humans at
the one recent study said and
now you question like it starts blurring
physical and digital physical and real
right what's real what's wrong and does
it matter well the actual study showed
that virtual humans can generate three
types of interest in physical humors
than real humans
so there's another fact for you second
one right
third story now we're going from
consumer grade to Industrial grade uh
this nvidia's Omnibus their version of
the metaverse and you should go check
out these videos because it's hyper
realistic they can mimic physics
they can do uh Shadows light Reflections
in such a way that you can prototype
real systems
in a way you couldn't do before and
multiple people around the world
synchronously can work together
using very different tools so
interoperability comes in as well so
these are all parts of our next virtual
world now this begs the question what is
the metaverse right
there's no one definition the metaverse
yet but what it is not is US walking
around wearing goggles that's what
people think today and that's not what
it is at all
it's just a fashion of the next internet
and when you start thinking often a
facet of the next internet it starts
feeling very different
it's it it's it's got some primary
features that are going to happen
persistent which means that whether you
go in and out of the world it's going to
exist uh immersive the 3D versus 2D by
the way you can look at a 3D World with
a 2d screen right as you saw uh
available in synchronous anyone can join
at any point many multiple people can
join in and it connects physical and
digital as you see in many ways
but that's the less interesting stuff
the more interesting stuff is on the
other side and that's what we should be
talking about the desirable features
that it's Creator shaped versus platform
shaped that it is interoperable versus
walled Gardens that we have today and
that is decentralized was a centralized
that's what you're going to debate about
but I'm going to talk about two
gravities that make the metabus
inevitable
okay the first one
technological gravity
look at these numbers the Investments
that are going into the mirrors today
mean that from a technical and
technological standpoint it is going to
happen
meta Facebook changes name to meta
invested 10 billion dollars a year and
plan to do that for the next decade
uh Microsoft they already own Minecraft
if anyone has a kid they play Minecraft
and Roblox and they are in the in the
process of buying Activision blizzards
70 billion dollars biggest acquisition
SoftBank 150 billion dollars into zepeto
which is Asia's biggest Med of us Google
which the Google Glasses remember those
Google Glasses they are going back into
AR VR
estimates 1.5 to 3 trillion there are
many other estimates the numbers are big
from a technical standpoint it is going
to happen
let's get to the second gravity
generational gravity
the foundations of the metabolas are
already here and are being used by
millions all these kids doing this
Fringe things like gaming social media
and buying nfts well they're going to
grow up and they're going to expect the
rest of work life and play to mimic that
Roblox 50 million daily users 97 of gen
Z customers your social media 17 billion
dollars of nft sales are from 82 million
right a year ago huge numbers so
Generations can expect this now let's
bring it back to Asia what does this
mean for us in this part of the world
well trillion dollar opportunity one
third of the global one is 60 of the
world's year
live in Asia
biggest Mobile gaming population 1.3
billion live in Asia
75 of the integrated circuits
manufacturing the same Hardware that's
going to go into the Next Generation
comes from Asia
Vietnam India and Pakistan the number
three countries for crypto Global crypto
adoption China South Korea and Japan
have Incorporated metaverse explicitly
into the economic plans and Singapore
and India are building guard rails to
protect against it so one last slide
two statements and one question
the metabus is inevitable I hope you
believe me by now but a human-centric
one is not that's what we had to work
for so the big question is how might we
design the metaverse we want thank you
thank you that was excellent please stay
there
do you want to come on stage with me
thank you for these two great
presentations and I can tell you they're
provocative because we got some pretty
good questions and some of them are do
they believe are provocative do they
believe me no
well you just asked the question so they
didn't answer that yet but
um there's been some like Rumblings
about the speculative you know like
amplitude of what we talked about so
well I'm gonna start doing something
that is maybe slightly unusual but you
might have questions for each other
do you or if you don't think about it
because I can start asking the first
question that
um that I think is a tough one and so
therefore it's interesting so
um so AI offers us a plethora of
knowledge that can be applied
imaginatively they move around
um to graph new ideas
we as individuals have limitations
so will designers become facilitators or
curators of what AI generates absolutely
absolutely yes so when designers
underestimate themselves hugely sorry to
say guys but this is absolutely true
because
um we have this huge respect for
scientists and they're very rational
deductive and inductive thinking but now
you're working with neuroelectrics for
instance some of the largest projects
that have come out of our community more
recently have been artificial life
uh and uh they work with neural networks
now for the past five to six years some
of them have been real become real
virtuosos and it has it is absolutely
certain that when it comes to the
outputs of neural networks
um the the the volume and also the
variety is so hard to grasp for linear
thinkers and we need alternative ways
through sometimes they create
visualization systems so it can grasp
the Salient moments but basically there
are various different strategies that
people who are trained to look at
subject matter for multiple perspectives
can actually offer new kind of entry
points into Illuminating the knowledge
that's coming out of these systems and
designers of course are trained 24 7 to
investigate the world in this way now
that it has been traditionally
questioned and there have been a lot of
sort of assumptions that this kind of
way of generating creating new knowledge
well we wasn't recognized as something
that was generating new knowledge it was
it was just perceived as being rather
chaotic because people couldn't track
and Trace exactly the train of thought
but the truth is that it actually offers
a rig when it's supplied rigorously and
most good designers do it is actually a
way that is used now to illuminate the
new knowledge that's required with these
new new systems it's the only way we can
unravel them yeah I I hear you and this
question yeah go ahead so uh I didn't
mention this but two of the images we
had the opening one and the close one
they're both from AI generated art and I
think that's become a big deal in the
last few weeks and months I think Dali
and everything else so it is
so I think we do have to think about how
humans and AI can work together there's
an example from chess that just came to
mind uh you know when um Gary Castro was
beaten by big blue right that is a big
deal but uh then they found out that if
you combined a human with the machine
they could actually beat the machine we
started a whole new series of games
called Central chess where humans and
their teams of humans with computers
coming together and I think we're going
to see more of that of uh human
intelligence and artificial intelligence
coming together so I have a question for
you that kind of comes together with
this can the metaverse address Injustice
and inequity or will it make it worse if
those companies win it well yeah that is
a big question right if we leave into
the powers to be it'll make it worse
uh so they are in I mean it brings back
one of the things we talked about
multiple times the idea of agency that
we do have to start
um playing uh
uh an active role in shaping it to what
it could be because if you were to leave
it to capitalism as it exists today it
probably will make things worse
so um there was one that I left but that
I lost because you're voting a lot so
thank you but I'm kind of losing track
but I confuse it there was one that was
really like what the hell are you
talking about this is cheesy but um this
is similar but better phrase so in the
face of multiple problems in society
today what are most designers focused on
um are in Singapore they say uh perhaps
e-commerce crypto big Tech Etc not all
it's not true
um uh but I lost it again are we living
up to our role as enzymes of progress
today I mean let's ask
um Singapore and then the EU okay yeah
you are the EU so on the question of
whether it is superficial absolutely
what you see today most of it is very
superficial and it frustrates me no end
we should do better like I don't care
about another board ape so why why is it
happening
because we've been trained to behave
that way in some way and we're also
driving for its speculative at this
point there's money to be made in
speculation
um and and we are you know kind of a
Tick-Tock culture so we're driven by
some of that too so but this community
here I think would think deeper and
that's why we need this community to
engage to get to the bigger problems to
get the left side of questions and how
we build an interoperable decentralized
um metaverse that can be better for all
of us
[Music]
good EU you work a lot no you you work a
lot with the EU yeah absolutely you know
there's also an issue of of design
education that I feel differentiates the
EU from other places but tell me
practice based design education most
definitely I mean very many parts it
slightly differs but but most definitely
so this idea of getting your hands dirty
translating thought into practice and
testing really the experience of course
it comes with foundational principles we
do not allow building of rather we
should not allow building of any systems
unless we have foundational principles
in place because it's a direct
reflection of our society so for
instance you know we talk big data and
this is we're talking you know metaphors
is data and content driven
uh we know I mean you can follow the
work of Joy bulomini at MIT I mean you
know there's there's horrific evidence
of of bias in data
um uh we know not everybody you know
we're computer scientists are given uh
data to work with they do not question
provenance for example so what we're
trying to do is create a system and this
is something that I've been working uh
on in this idea of Industry comments
which has been really recognized at the
European commission which is the idea
that not only are we creating a space of
common understanding between the
different disciplines or between the
industries for various reasons one
because we need to track and Trace
provenance of materials and products if
we're going to create sustainability
but also because we need to actually
create layers of accountability within
those systems so that we can actually
for instance you know if you follow Kate
Roller's donut economy we don't want to
hit that ceiling so you want to embed
that in the system and also you want to
base the system on agreements that not
they're not just regulatory but there
are also systems of agreements and
accountability or attribution of
intellectual property for every single
participant or every single creative
that's part of this process but then
ultimately you know and also of course
responsible AI uh social and corporate
social responsibility or ethics but then
at the basis of it are our societal
foundational principles which of course
where for instance we can have inclusion
radical inclusion as a base element in
this Big Data Systems otherwise if if we
consider data in isolation and the way
that our computer scientists have been
trained to look at it we will completely
ignore and this is what has brought us
all these problems we will encro in
ignore provenance we will not annotate
with where does this belong to we'll end
up with white middle-aged men or you
know dictating basically what the what
the metaverse looks like I mean I don't
think that's going to be a particularly
good result for anybody I'm not sure
that it's going to happen there's too
many people involved but this I had
another separate question but this leads
me to another question that has been
asked here which is it's kind of like a
boomerang right back at you uh how do we
design the metaverse then
um well so the left side of things
what's going to be driving
decision making around that it's going
to be two things business models like
how do you how would anyone make money
off of this and regulation so I'm going
to refer back to Aaron because every
talk has to refer back to Aaron
and we gotta go to the seven principles
and I think the fact that Singapore
Australia India and a few countries are
leaning in in Asia Europe is definitely
leaning in to set up those regulatory
guard rails is going to be one of the
saving Graces for what the metaverse
could be
so that's one part the second part is we
need a few
um bold leaders in business in
technology
to start thinking of different business
models beyond what exists today
that actually honor more kinds of value
so we need we need someone to step up to
do that I think in order to make this
work we need both of those things now
talking about is
um understood by most in certain circles
circles that are both generational and
cultural I wonder if institutions also
are
um accepting not only of new languages
and new models but also up and what this
is one of the questions a criticality
that they should have there should be
self-criticism in order to change their
mindsets do you encounter that problem
or usually these the civil servants that
you're working with understand where
where's the obstacle yeah uh so I can
tell you from experience at high level
we have people who are really pushing
the agenda and they really are brave
enough to engage Grassroots communities
and actually ask them to test things on
the ground so basically our our
perception particularly in the new
European barhouses the initiative that
is actually really connecting Grassroots
communities and it's driven by culture
and by Design designers and by
Architects to actually facilitate this
space where we test drive these systems
I mean the reason that we test drive all
these systems as I have just shown is
that when people kind of discuss
regulation at high level they actually
have no hands-on experience so how that
might affect people so what we want to
do is connect this from the ground up
and actually illuminate this with proper
knowledge that is how is this affecting
The Human Experience so in this sense
there has been a great deal of Courage
on the other hand implementation is a
massive challenge because it's that
layer of civil servant for instance we
started to work with the regions a great
deal and there are some fantastic
champions in the regions I mean there's
intelligent people everywhere you know
it's just that we are also discussing
the reframing of the idea of a civil
servant as not as someone who is
implementing
directives from the top but as someone
who is a mediator between the Community
ideas and the the tangible experience
and the tangible results and Innovations
are happening on the ground which are
happening everywhere we collected
thousands and thousands of amazing
examples and then mediating between that
and the people at the top so basically
creating this bottom-up top-down
dialogue that can further enable
communities to thrive and to innovate
more and we do need to engage in this
way because there's absolutely no way
that a few directors from the top are
going to change the game and we don't I
mean in Europe we actually believe that
in terms of the green deal there isn't
enough time we need to engage everyone
now I'm sorry about the most voted uh
question is something that is like oh
come on so the silkworms in Mary oxman's
Pavilion all die off and don't fly
peacefully away no it's the opposite
this is the same kind of exploitation as
for textiles it's not
um how is this a good example
how is this a good example for
regenerative practice no the larvae poop
and then they do their silk and they
become they become butterflies in Mary's
Pavilions they fly away in the silk
industry they get boiled out of their
cocoon so that the Cocoon can so that
you can extract the thread from the
Cocoon so in other words uh no they live
a better life I think because how can we
know what a better life is and that's
really seriously now it's been facetious
so the conditions are better for Nary
silkworms than the ones in the silk
industry but still the the Holy Grail is
to be able to understand what nature
wants
um and what animals and boulders wants
and that that's why I mean I kind of
argue for a new kind of animism which
you can find more usual more often in
Native cultures than you can find in our
in our sophisticated synthetic culture
so that's why
um what many have been talking about out
Sarah among them the idea of
recuperating
saying indigenous is kind of the wrong
word but indigenous wisdom but there's a
an artist Ursula biman that I like very
much that talks about the figure of the
indigenous scientists so I would add to
natsai's grandmothers and other roles
the idea of the indigenous scientists
because so much of the Native science
has been obliterated by colonialism for
instance in so much of South America and
in places like Colombia for instance
there's a very Advanced cultural system
that really looks at Native wisdom and
gives personhood to Nature to recuperate
that native wisdom also with
contemporary legal Frameworks so in
other words
Mary's silkworms are fine but we need to
do so much more work to get us to
understand absolutely so I mean
ecosystemic approaches so so what has
really changed to us at EU level and
bearing in mind you know I keep saying
because this is an initiative launched
by the European Commission because it's
in line with the green deal but we
actually have Shigeru bun on the high
level Roundtable and we have Sheila
Patel who works with women's communities
in India absolutely phenomenally
inspiring for me because she keeps
pulling us away from the neurocentric
perspective which it needs to be done
because no matter where you're from you
will resort to your own sort of backyard
and we have recently onboarded three new
members of the high level Roundtable
including Francis Carey the Pittsburgh
price winner and and two phenomenal
other people so we really are insisting
on this global perspective on the
subject but what has happened as a
result of the involvement of this
amazing uh colleagues that I I'm very
privileged to be working with at this
level is the openness of the high level
policy makers to the suggestions from us
so whereas before it used to take a long
time for paradigms to shift for policy
makers so just to illustrate a case in
point we had in 2017 Germany proclaimed
industry 4.0
as Automation and the creative community
and the design Community just shouted
out and saying where's the human
perspective in this a few years later
2021 the entire research and Innovation
program which is enormous it's one of
the biggest things in the world funded
programs actually prioritized
human-centric as industry 5.0 so they go
with Version Control you have to forgive
them
um and then and that was 2021 in we
immediately straight after we said yes
but we need to go ecosystemic from our
perspective because unless we introduce
ecosystemic thinking into industry we
are still failing miserably if we just
go human-centric and so I can bet you
anything around you know speaking
publicly now that they will probably
come up with industry 6.0 next version
control because very very soon because
because already in the conference in
February that was the industry that
European industry days the whole week
they spoke about in ecosystem they're
trying to survive they're trying to
survive wow it's a fight for survival
from all sides but we will prevail we'll
weed like the designers would prevail
dinner all right thank you both very
very much